okay so let's let's talk about we
we're going to cover both but i want to
see which one you want to do first do
you want to cover
a little more of the propaganda you want
to talk about the relief bill in like
detail because we got a lot of little
things that came out of it because
i don't know if you know this it was 5
200 pages and you know how long they had
to read it
two hours yeah it's always what they do
i know but it's
but it's worth repeating yeah i know
yeah it's yeah let's i mean let's do
that let's
okay cool yeah because this is fun nice
nice
it was a 900 900 billion dollar covet
stimulus package
okay and here's what was here here's
what was in it let's check it out here
we go
uh um
six hundred dollars to american citizens
cool right
it's not bad right not bad forty million
dollars for the kennedy center the same
love that candidates
didn't kennedy center get what 20
million likes
and then they fired everybody what's
under the kennedy center that's so
important
i don't know that's where they keep it
that's where they're keeping john
robert kennedy junior bro he's in a
bunker
uh 154 million for the national gallery
of art
oh good thank god gallery of heart
um one billion for the smithsonian
institute
by the way somebody in the chat dorothy
in the chat says trump better veto what
[ __ ] planet are you living on he's
not vetoing this
he's gonna push it right through this is
this is now the
exclamation point at the end of the
sentence that donald trump
turns out wasn't our buddy uh
14 million dollars for the and mike mike
and i were talking affair we're like
mike
i was like what's going to happen to the
woodrow wilson center it's all he's been
talking
that's frankly really i don't stop i'm
like very annoying what about
the wardrobe wilson center that when i
don't know
enough well good news mike i'll shut up
now because he's
it's getting 14 million dollars thank
god
167 million is going into the national
foundation on arts and humanities
great another leftist organization he's
nice
and look the next one before i read i
want to point something out a lot of
americans are suffering okay their
businesses are closed
um san francisco right now just said
that there's more you saw that more
overdose deaths than covet deaths going
on in san francisco
um schooling is a mess there's gonna be
a lot of kids are gonna be repeating
grades because they just
you can't get the right education over a
zoom meeting
so um the good news is
you're gonna get 700 million dollars
if you live in sudan well that's great
so if you live in sudan it's great news
seven for the sudanese this is great 700
because this culver bill which is
supposed to be about you know
america they're gonna get 700 million
and you know what mike
the bengals are excited not the team the
band yep
because egypt's getting 1.3 billion i
like it
uh and of course what's more important
than our
asia funds 1.4 billion for the asia
reassurance initiative
act now i looked up what it was i really
try to
research this it is like a thousand
pages of
just political like little little
just basically handouts to countries
that aren't north korea
yeah well you know we had to to be
honest i i did read the bill
uh in its entirety uh line by line
you're so sleepy
i know that's and and the the main thing
with the asia reassurance initiative act
it's basically just reparations for
everything shane gillis said this year
oh seth gilligan yeah seth gilliam
and uh and uh so that's we we had to pay
reparations to the agency that's
that so you can thank him for that
that's fair thanks a lot man yeah thanks
shingilis
then 135 million for burma which by the
way
surprised about this burma still exists
did you know that
i didn't a i didn't know it still
existed b why are we giving them 135
million dollars when they have all those
[ __ ] rubies the size of tangerines
it's a movie and that was michael kane
saying it i believe
that's right it wrote b decision for
tangerine oh
clearly they have money what can we at
least get the tangerine sized rubies no
they keep both they keep the rubies and
the money
they burned to forest fast away
um there's a lot dude when you go back
and re-watch those batman movies
i'm starting to learn they're pretty bad
like they're they're awesome for what
they are
but when you really start paying
attention to the batman movies they're
pretty bad
so the next one is 85 million for
cambodia
uh 135 million when i was in cambodia oh
stop a tangerine the size of a ruby
those are very small tangerines they
were just a small tangerine
excised they brought to them they
brought it to our hotel
a little bit they would bring them up
little sh shirtless lady boys
would bring them up to the hotel room
wait i'm sorry back up mr kane shirtless
i'm sorry alfred
this was back when i worked for your
father before he hired
people oh okay i got it all right yes
this is the whole side plot of batman is
is alfred
really has an issue with [ __ ] lucious
with lucious fox
i remember when your father wouldn't
even hire those types of people
forget making your batsuit you're
letting him press your clothes
so 135 million for nepal well yeah of
course
and of course you know one of our
greatest allies right away the socialist
country of venezuela is getting 33
million
we're bailing out wow that's like 75
billion in venezuelan dollars
you could buy venezuela for 33 million
dollars probably we're talking
with change you're watching that's
disgusting
um and then of course 453 million for
the ukraine
they get a little little taste you can
get a little taste where was uh i'm
curious just
remind me again vice pres uh the
president-elect joe biden
uh he has a son right yes and
well he used to have two sons um but he
has
one son left he worked in the energy
field in the energy sector right that's
correct and
i if i remember the company was a
foreign company where was that company
located
i want to say the ukraine somewhere in
that area yeah
no no it was actually in the ukraine
okay well then there you go
453 million dollars but they're paying
them in crack
so crack rocks the size of tangerines
must away we're always in burma
we smoke crack rocks the size of ruby
sized tangerines so ruby says crack
ted's
read size ruby crack rocks
are they bigger i mean even a ruby size
crack rocks a big crack rock
it would be a pretty well it depends on
the cut no and by the way so i haven't
admitted it i was about to get to that
next um
this this covert bill was all part of a
larger spending bill
it was i looked it up so it was it was
part of a larger spending bill
the spending bill also gives uh
i want to make sure i get it right
because i don't want i don't want to i
don't want to over exaggerate i don't
want people how much are they getting
how much are they how much are they
getting like i don't
even by the way i was kidding about
having seen the bill how much are they
how much do you think they're getting
if you have to guess
one time shot mind you this isn't like
over like they get 3.8 but
one time shot how much you think they're
getting in the spending bill not now the
spending bill is part of the covet bill
one time shot i'm gonna
save 100 million 500 million
they're getting 500 million
now keep in mind
this is uh it's noted that this this is
part of the
appropriations package that the covet
bill is a part
so they didn't put it in the covet bill
but it's part of the appropriations
package it's connected to the copic bill
you know yeah just carry it forward it's
fine just give them whatever they want
uh space force gets two billion give
them whatever they want
space force is getting two billion
dollars you have 500 million dollars
oh that's oh that's great that's good
stuff
that's good stuff i knew they were
i knew they were getting a cut i knew it
uh yeah it's part of the entire omnibus
appropriations bill which contains the
coven relief as a cover relief bill
so why are you so blackpilled
i love this i like this
embrace the suck baby that's it it's
like look at this point culturally we're
at the point where
like you know that they always tell you
embrace the suck when the guys are in
the [ __ ]
like like vietnam guys and there's that
first couple of weeks where they're just
like
jittery and they're scared to die and
all that stuff and then you get that
thousand-yard stare and you've been
there for
months and then you get to that point
where you just [ __ ]
ride it baby like i that's it man that's
what i want to be
the cultural equivalent of the guy who's
like a machine gunner in vietnam
and he's just mainlining every day
and just chain smoking cigarettes and
doesn't even duck when the mortars
are coming off anywhere he just hops on
his gun and goes
[Laughter]
shoots heroin and is like let's [ __ ]
ride it baby
that's what we need to do because
there's no one like you can say
oh it's blackfield but it's like i i
want to be able to navigate this
and keep my sanity so you know